Radtke: Hi.
My name's Autumn.
And I want to take
a quick second
to talk to you
about our Android application
Geodelic.
Geodelic is a location-based
discovery platform
that allows users quickly
and easily discover
the most relevant information
wherever they are.
Um, I want to give you
a quick demo of the application.
This is the user interface.
When you launch the app,
you don't have to do anything.
It immediately works
and discovers your surroundings.
Um, you can easily
and quickly filter
based on what
you're looking for.
So maybe--sorry--
maybe you're hungry.
Maybe you need a caffeine fix
or you're looking for your bank.
You can filter based
on any of the amenities
you're currently looking for.
So here we have
Bank of America.
Because it's a bank,
maybe you want to connect
to CNN.
Maybe you want to get
stock reviews
about that location.
And so whatever
would be relevant
about that point of interest,
we want to deliver to you
in one or two clicks.
The carousel interface
helps us in a lot of ways
because the GPS technology
is not always super accurate.
So the carousel,
if we're not spot on--
if we can't always find
exactly where you are--
you're just a swipe away
from finding the place
that you're interested in.
And it also represents
what someone does in real life
if they're looking around
at the things around them.
So we find that the carousel
really helps the user interact
in a way that's interesting.
We also have several views
of that information.
We have a map view
so that you can see
where these places are located
on an actual map.
We also have a list view.
For some people,
it's easier to filter that way.
And then you can get
"click to call,"
"click to route"
about any of these places.
And so I can easily
just make a call
to those people.
Maybe I want to make
a reservation.
And we also have these widgets
down here, which you can see.
Menus. OpenTable.
Nutritional information.
So we dynamically
assemble widgets
that we think will be relevant
to the place you are.
Like I said,
if it's a restaurant,
maybe you want to get
what's on the menu
or make a reservation.
If you're at
the grocery store,
we'll give you recipes,
we'll give you
a calorie counter.
Maybe you need to make
a vegan dish.
So we reorganize information
based on your context.
We get your context
from where you are.
And we think that that's the--
that's the pillar
of--of what your circumstances
might be.
If you're at a cafe,
we immediately direct you
to New York Times content,
Perez Hilton,
'cause we think
you might have some time.
You might want to do
some reading.
And so the idea here
is to make it quick and easy
for the user
to access information
based on their context.
Where in other location-based
services,
they're really focused
on the map
and navigating
from place to place,
we're really about navigating
the information
that's relevant to a place.
And we think Android
is--is the best platform
to begin doing this on,
uh, for a lot of reasons.
Um, open development
and in Java
makes it easy
to get great talent
to make great applications
like this.
Um, from a distribution
perspective,
you've got the opportunity work
on multiple devices.
Um, it's easy for the consumer
to get the application.
They don't have to sync it
to another device.
It also--from a developer's
perspective--
is easy for us to push
new updates,
um, as new builds come out.
The opportunity to be able
to run multiple applications,
um, cuts out
the start-up time.
So when you go back
into the environment,
it's much quicker
and much more receptive,
which is what you really want
as an application.
You want the people
to keep coming back
so that you can provide them
this utility.
And so we think Geodelic
is going to be part
of the next wave
of location-based services
on the mobile platforms.
So a little bit about Geodelic
as a company.
Uh, we were founded
over a year ago
by a guy by the name
of Rahul Sonnad,
who's been in the business
for a long time.
We have, uh,
we're venture backed
and we're now over 20 people.
Uh, so we've got some really
great talent involved.
Um, our CTO
was the chief scientist
at Shopzilla
for the past six years.
Um, so we're really confident
that we'll be able
to provide great technology
to the consumer.
And as far as, uh, potentially
monetizing this,
um, the application
will be free.
So we want to get it
in the hands
of as many users as possible
and not give them any barriers
to entry.
And also, we're using partners
like coupons.com, for instance,
who will distribute timely,
contextual coupons
into the application
so that users can take advantage
of that.
And that's also a monetization
opportunity for us
as well as content providers
who will share revenue with us
to distribute their application
in a contextual manner.
So as the application
will be free,
we will have ads
in the application.
And our aim is to provide
the ads that don't degrade
from the experience,
but are contextually relevant
and add to the user's experience
so that maybe they can get
a dollar off their sub
when they're close
to SUBWAY.
And so that's the advantage
we have
of knowing where the user is
and being able
to provide them
with the most utility
and even be able to provide them
with material value
while they're using
the application.
So that's it
for Geodelic for now.
We're having a great time
at Google I/O
and can't wait to see you guys
again next year.